they're proud of where they come from
here in new jersey adam loewy was born
here he works for his parents moving
company but today the 27 year old isn't
transporting furniture but food which he
and his team have collected
often when people move house they leave
behind cans or other packaged food
it turns out 40 of the food on this
planet goes to waste people just throw
away food um and it's even more so when
people are relocating it's the last
thing that people think of uh when
they're moving they're thinking about
making sure that their their furniture
their tv
or their dvd player gets
to their new home in one piece
and
what's in their pantries is often the
last thing thought about
adam drops off what he's collected at a
food bank
from here foodstuffs are distributed to
soup kitchens or directly to poor
families in new jersey
what's going on all right thank you so
much adam thank you
in some parts of the state one in 10
people don't have enough to eat
rice noodles and grain products are
sorted
peanut butter is a much needed staple
since it contains a lot of protein
but every type of ready-made meal is
welcome
adam studied marketing and had a
well-paid job at mercedes at the age of
23 he started his move for hunger
organization now more than 500 moving
companies have joined but it all started
in new jersey
there's a hundred thousand people
in the home of bruce springsteen and bon
jovi and heather locklear and the jersey
shore and you don't see
all this poverty all around and no one's
talking about it um
so it was it was kind of that statistic
that made me start to think you know
what what is hunger hunger's clearly
here but the reality is that one in six
americans 50 million americans go to bed
hungry every night
new jersey is near new york city where
as the song goes if you can make it here
you can make it anywhere
but for many liberty has its limits
you can quickly end up struggling
the homeless have long been an all too
common part of city life
adam visits new york often because he's
joined the global shapers network along
with artists politicians economists and
environmentalists they all exchange
ideas organize events and draw awareness
to various problems and they're all
younger than
30. but like no really like clouds
haven't really specified the goal yeah i
mean like when you're starting a company
you're very focused on that company and
sometimes it's it's a little bit
isolated but i think you can really
benefit from meeting other people who
have fresh perspectives you know no two
people in the globe global shapers
program are alike no two people have the
same background or are doing the same
thing you really have access to a
diversity of talents perspectives
passions and that helps you
have a little bit more
objectivity in whatever it is that
you're doing and also discover and
brainstorm new ideas to impact the world
caroline is working to improve equal
opportunities for women in the workplace
in 2012 she and a friend started livo
league which helps young women get
started in their chosen careers
a former advisor at mckenzie she wants
them to profit from others experience
for many here volunteering is a matter
of course
young people want to do something the
vast majority of young people in the
united states and across the globe
have a cause they're passionate about
whether their aunt had breast cancer or
they care about the oceans because
they're a surfer so young people just
need impactful
fun exciting meaningful things to do and
they will do something
adam was 23 years old when he started
move for
hunger but some people are even younger
when they become activists
and they use networks which are becoming
increasingly important together they can
do more than on their own
you